[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 26 mai face à
la menace du variant indien la france va
mettre en place un isolement obligatoire
pour les voyageurs en provenance du
royaume uni dans ce contexte d'accalmie
toujours fragile sur le front du coc vie
d'une préconisation de l'académie de
médecine fait débat elle estime
indispensable de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire et recommande de vacciner
enfants et adolescents alors la
vaccination doit elle être obligatoire
la situation sanitaire l'exigé ou
l'exigera tel ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face on
les aides publiques à la presse si le
ministère de la culture avait pris
l'habitude de publier chaque année leur
montant pour chaque titre et groupe de
presse cette pratique est tombé dans
l'oubli depuis maintenant trois ans
cette année n'échappe pas à la règle
mais le site d'investigation la lettre a
a pu nous éclairer un peu sur cette
répartition des 225 millions d'euros en
l'avenir d'un territoire en jeu avant la
troisième et dernière consultation sur
l'indépendance prévu d'ici octobre 2022
exécutif réuni les élus de l'archipel
pour étudier les scénarios du oui ou du
non
une semaine décisive de discussion qui a
débuté aujourd'hui par une rencontre
entre jean castex et les responsables
politiques de l'archipel
[Musique]
la circulation de l'épidémie est de
moins en moins actives en france mais
n'est pas pour autant sous contrôle les
taux d'incidence reste un taux élevé sur
tout le territoire
c'est dans ce contexte de fragile des
crues du coc vite que l'académie de
médecine s'est prononcé pour la
vaccination obligatoire relançant ainsi
les débats pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite david khalifa
bonsoir david haye les réactions n'ont
pas manqué un dans de suite à cette
déclaration surtout dans le milieu
médical
un peu moins du côté des politiques
effectivement et stéphanie a beaucoup de
réactions parce qu'on tient négative 1
suite à cette déclaration de patrick
berche plusieurs spécialistes sont
montés au créneau cas les français on se
souvient était déjà sceptique à l'idée
de cette vaccination jean paul hamon est
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france ne veut surtout pas à
brusquer les français a dû côté de la rs
on préconise de l' impatience écoute et
ce n'est pas le moment de braquer les
gens inutilement
on commence à avoir suffisamment de
doses pour vacciner les gens laissons
faire on verra bien au mois de septembre
octobre dans quelle situation sera mais
parti comme c'est parti on est parti
pour vacciner près de 10 millions de
personnes par mois il faut être patient
pour l'instant plein de gens veulent se
faire vacciner et on n'a pas assez de
vaccins
les rendez vous ne sont pas faciles à
obtenir le jour où tous ceux qui
voulaient se faire vacciner se sont fait
vacciner et qu'on voit un frein dans la
campagne de vaccination liés à
l'adhésion
peut-être qu'on pourra se poser la
question rendre un vaccin obligatoire
peut être en train à l'adhésion
vaccinale vous savez comment sont les
français
il suffit de leur dire que quelque chose
est obligatoire pour qu'ils imaginent
quelque chose de louche derrière pour
l'académie de médecine je le rappelle ça
serait le moyen le plus sûr pour
atteindre à cette fameuse immunité
collective 1 ce qui signifie à 90% de la
population vaccinée mais l'aspect
d'obligations a subjugué certains
politiques notamment florian philippot
le
dehors des patriotes appelle les
français à se révolter
regardez voilà nous y sommes
l'académie de médecine préconise de
rendre obligatoire le vaccin pour de
nombreuses catégories de français et de
vacciner enfants et adolescents la
terreur qu'ovide east franchi une
nouvelle étape
réveillons nous c'est l'une des rares et
action politique on a pu observer sur
les réseaux sociaux peu d'élus souhaite
remettre le sujet sur la table dans la
majorité comme dans l'opposition car la
question considérée comme de santé
publique par l'académie de médecine
restent très sensibles et david la
question évidemment que se posent
beaucoup de français c'est savoir si le
gouvernement peut donc l'imposer et
rendre effectivement cette vaccination
obligatoire et bien stéphanie dans ce
contexte d'urgence sanitaire tout est
possible mais l exécutif a toujours été
contre cette idée emmanuel macron écarté
lui même cette hypothèse la semaine
dernière affirmant le respect l de la
vie de chacun je préfère marcher par la
conviction selon ses mots mais gabriel
atallah lui était un peu plus évasif cet
après midi le porte parole du
gouvernement a dit entendre ses
recommandations ce sont des études que
nous regardons en fin de citation mais
notre objectif reste de vacciner ceux
qui le souhaitent pour le moment voilà
l'option est sur la table nul doute que
si une telle décision est prise les anti
vaccin serait furieux pour le moment ils
sont 20% de la population selon les
derniers chiffres annoncés
d'autant plus que pour le moment dans le
monde aucun pays n'a contraint ses
citoyens à se faire vacciner
merci david kelly fin en direct de
l'académie de médecine
alors faut-il rendre le vaccin
obligatoire la situation sanitaire
l'exigé ou l'exigera tel de toute façon
pour espérer retrouver une vie normale
c'est l'objet de notre face à face mais
avec nous pour en parler frédéric
lapostolle professeur de médecine
d'urgence à l'hôpital avicenne à bobigny
en région parisienne à ses côtés idriss
aberkane enseignants conférencier et
séisme bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on vient de voir laquelle est mis en
médecine qui préconise de rendre le
vaccin contre le coc vide obligatoires
votre position tout d'abord frédéric
lapostolle sait ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui l'obligation la contrainte
en tout état de cause aujourd'hui non la
réponse là dessus et est clair quand on
quand on lit le titre finalement il est
assez éclairant puisque c'est
l'obligation n'est pas un gros mot et
l'intérêt ce débat finalement la
question posée à terme si on veut si on
veut s'en sortir
herman de cette pique aujourd'hui assez
j apporte une lumière c'est la
vaccination
on était à 60 % de personnes réticentes
au début du mois de décembre
on est aujourd'hui vous l'avais dit aux
alentours de 20%
donc le travail de conviction la
multiplication des exemples nationaux et
internationaux sont plutôt rassurants
si on devait avoir du mal à atteindre le
seuil suffisant pour avoir une immunité
collective
la question se posera je pense que
l'essentiel pour l'académie de médecine
était d'ouvrir le débat
alors le débat est ouvert et on discute
ce soir ils disent à berkane
la vaccination obligatoire pas un gros
mot pour vous non plus sinon c'est un
groupe à plusieurs raisons parce que on
a certains pays comme la norvège ou
l'irlande ou le japon qui ne sont pas
des pays particulièrement idiot qui
n'ont même pas jugé nécessaire de rendre
la vaccination obligatoire pour la rage
et pour d'autres maladies beaucoup plus
dangereuse que la callas coville 19
comme l'hépatite à ou l'hépatite b dans
évidemment chacun sait qu'elles sont
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus létal
donc si dans des pays comme le japon
l'irlande ou la norvège
la vaccination contre la rage n'est pas
obligatoire la vaccination contre
l'hépatite a et l'hépatite b n'est pas
obligatoire mais que bien entendu les
gens s'informent et vont se faire
vacciner dans les conditions nécessaires
mais sa forme aussi dans certains cas
sur les complications post vaccinale qui
reste bien entendu aussi très rare mais
c'est ça le fondement de la médecine
c'est là le consentement éclairé et dès
lors qu'on parle d' obligations on
oublie le fondement fondamentale et
absolue et non négociable de la médecine
qui est le consentement éclairé et dont
la seule exception comme on le sait et
la psychiatrie donc considérer qu'on va
devoir obliger les français à se
vacciner c'est au fond commencer à
envisager finalement de les considérer
partiellement irresponsable de leur axe
et ça c'est quelque chose qui selon moi
n'est pas envisageable
frédéric la poste ans est intéressant ce
que nous dit idriss à berkane
est-ce que c'est comparable avec les
vaccins de la rage et de l'hépatite à
rappelons évidemment que c'est un virus
qui est contagieux ça veut dire qu'au
nom de la santé publique collective il
faut que chacun fasse un effort
individuel et soit comme on le dit
monsieur aberkane soit d'une certaine
manière sous la contrainte 1 et renonce
à ses libertés individuelles alors il ya
aucune comparaison possible parce que le
vaccin contre la rage n'est absolument
pas un vaccin obligatoire
le vaccin contre l'hépatite à n'est
absolument pas un vaccin obligatoire
le vaccin contre l'hépatite b c'est un
bon exemple parce que c'est un vaccin
qui est obligatoire pour les
professionnels de santé et qui a permis
de faire quasiment disparaître la
contamination du personnel lui
le problème avec le vaccin de l'hépatite
b il était différent c'est à dire que
c'est le personnel qui était contaminée
il y avait un nombre significatif de
personnel qui attrapait par leur
exercice professionnel une hépatite b
aujourd'hui sa quasi complètement
disparu de nos établissements
hospitaliers parce que le personnel est
vaccinée donc on est dans des situations
qui sont fondamentalement différentes
évidemment le consentement du patient
est une pièce la pierre angulaire de
l'exercice de la médecine
pour autant il ya déjà des vaccinations
qui sont obligatoires j'ai évoqué les
professionnels de santé mais à d'autres
vaccinations qui sont obligatoires pour
toute la population en particulier chez
les enfants et en particulier des
vaccins contre le tétanos contre la
tuberculose contre la diphtérie et à ma
connaissance la plupart des pays ont eu
recours à des campagnes de vaccination
massives pour se débarrasser de ces
virus faut pas oublier que la
tuberculose dans certains pays tue
encore beaucoup est le seul la seule
façon à moyen terme de se débarrasser de
ces maladies
c'est les campagnes de vaccination et en
france on voit bien que dans les
départements comme en seine saint denis
par exemple ou à certains moments il ya
des failles il ya des trous dans le
filet ya des trous dans la raquette sur
les campagnes de vaccination sur la
tuberculose
il ya une résurgence d'une maladie grave
qu'est la tuberculose
donc oui le patient doit consentir à
l'évidence néanmoins il faut pas oublier
que il ya des considérations de santé
publique qui font que il ya des choix
qui échappe pour partie aux patients
parce que sinon il n'y a pas de vie en
société
idrissa berkane sur cet argument
évidemment implacable on a tous envie de
retrouver une vie comme avant qu'est ce
que vous répondez comme peut-être
certains il ya d'autres traitements il
ya d'autres manières on ne peut pas
utiliser la contrainte mais tout de même
il semblerait en tout cas on nous
présente comme ça qu'aujourd'hui ça sera
peut-être la seule solution vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec ça et non parce qu'on
fait de la science et que la médecine
est une science autant qu'une pratique
et qu'on a absolument pas de preuve
scientifique de ce que c'est la seule
solution
tout d'abord donc on avait parlé
de quatre maladies très immunisante il
est vrai qu'on ne peut absolument pas
comparer ni la tuberculose ni l'hépatite
c qui sont les maladies pour lesquelles
la vaccination donne d'excellents
résultats
pareil pour les ménages les méninges au
coq mais en tout état de cause on a pas
du tout de données sur le caractère
immunisant déco vite de la coop 19 et de
ses différentes variations puisque c'est
un virus qui mute énormément notamment
avec sa protéine spike et sur lequel on
n'a pas de données d'immunisation
fiables aujourd'hui par ailleurs et là
ça va être un point de vue à la fois
légal et politique
la liberté est un droit imprescriptible
et ça ça dépasse la médecine c'est
quelque chose qui je sais pour un
professionnel défend de santé peut être
particulièrement difficile et je ne
parle pas du tout du professeur
lapostolle en particulier qui quelqu'un
de tout à fait sérieux mais quand on est
dans son dans son métier en particulier
on peut avoir tendance à l'oublier quel
que soit le métier
l'imprescriptibilité absolue totale de
la liberté qui ne peut être attribué ni
par la faculté ni par les autorités
politiques la liberté est un droit de
naissance fondamentale de l'être humain
elle est inscrite dans notre
constitution et ce droit de l'essence
est imprescriptible
en aucun cas une autorité constituée
même s'il s'agit d'une faculté de
médecine ne peut prescrire ce droit si
elle devait le prescrire dans une
situation catastrophique qui serait
votée et reconnu comme tel ce qui n'est
pas le cas
eh bien il faudrait impérativement que
les données scientifiques soit totale
est indiscutable or pour l'instant sur
l'immunisation avec les vaccins
prototypique que nous avons actuellement
les données scientifiques sont très loin
d'être totale en tout cas vous venez de
citer on va donner la parole évidemment
à frédéric la postale pour vous de
répondre mais vous citiez les politiques
le gouvernement rappelle lui était assez
frileux il ya encore quelques semaines
je vous propose d'écouter olivier
ferrand les propos datent de janvier
dernier
l'objectif est d'avoir les moyens de
vacciner tout le monde mais ça ne veut
pas dire que ce sera obligatoire
frédéric lapostolle bon ça veut pas dire
que ça sera obligatoire emmanuel macron
ne le souhaite pas non plus vraiment
bien
on sent quand même que l'idée jeter un
petit peu dans dans l'air on sait que le
conseil l'académie de médecine
travaillent souvent en collaboration
avec le gouvernement ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il se dit ce
gouvernement qu'on a pas le choix on
quelles sont ses arrière-pensées s'il y
en a vous imaginez bien que j'ignore
tout des arrière pensées du gouvernement
par contre je jouerai où il a justement
je voudrais réagir sur sur deux choses
le premier le principe de liberté
évidemment il est absolument fondamental
il n'en demeure pas moins que la vie en
société impose un certain nombre de
contraintes parce qu'on peut très bien
dire aussi qu'au titre de la liberté
je roule à la vitesse qui me convient
quand je suis sur l'autoroute et je fais
fi des risques que je prends moi même et
que je fais prendre aux autres non non
la vie en société impose d'avoir un
certain nombre de règles et ces règles
de temps en temps effectivement peuvent
paraître pour certains incompatible avec
la liberté et je m'inscris en faux sur
les assertions qui consiste à dire que
nous n'avons pas l'épreuve
sauf à imaginer que tous ceux qui ont
publié les résultats ce qui serait quand
même hautement improbable compte tenu de
la diversité des équipes qui ont
travaillé sur le sujet tous aujourd'hui
propose un vaccin qui sur ce qui nous
importe c'est à dire la prévention de la
mortalité la prévention des formes
coupable c'est ça qui a mis en péril
l'équilibré et l'impossibilité de gérer
les patients à l'hôpital tous affichent
des résultats qui sont excellents alors
on peut imaginer que les chinois se sont
mis d'accord avec les américains qui se
sont mis d'accord avec les européens qui
se sont mis d'accord avec les russes
pour donner tous des résultats trafic et
on peut l'imaginer
tout ce qui a été publié aujourd'hui
donne pour la prévention des formes
graves et des décès une efficacité qui
est au moins de 90% avec les vaccins qui
sont actuellement utilisées en france et
ça on voit bien que les pays qui ont
recouru avant nous à la vaccination qui
ont aujourd'hui des taux élevés de
vaccination
sont en train de lever l'essentiel des
barrières et si on arrive à vacciner et
à pouvoir lever les distensions sociales
et toutes les restrictions on n'aura pas
besoin d'aller plus loin mais je crois
que ce que le gouvernement se garde
c'est une porte ouverte pour aller plus
loin si la campagne de vaccination
n'atteignait pas l'immunité collective
alors en tout cas en russie en a sa
petite idée puisqu'il ya une forme de
scepticisme qu'on retrouve évidemment
aussi en france l'ancien président à
dmitri medvedev plaide lui justement
pour une vaccination obligatoire pour
espérer augmenter ce taux de vaccination
en russie mais vadimir poutine ne semble
pas convaincu et côté le président russe
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs échoué encore une
fois je tiens à exprimer ma position par
rapport à cela
à mon avis il ne faut pas imposer la
vaccination obligatoire
c'est inopportun initial samu m
les citoyens doivent eux mêmes prendre
conscience de cette nécessité comprendre
que s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés il
pourrait faire face à un danger très
grave voire mortelle d'un jeu snake et
la poste cela concerne surtout les
personnes âgées
idrissa berkane pour vous il est
inapproprié d'un point de vue
psychologique de force et c'est
contre-productif comme semble expliqué
vladimir poutine
vous savez en général quand un canton
produit marche quel qu'il soit quand une
solution marche scientifiquement c'est
tout de même assez étrange et incongru
de voir la rendent obligatoire mais j'ai
vu une petite épiphanie la vis-à-vis des
arguments du professeur lapostolle ce
tantôt alors je me suis dit que
peut-être il avait raison peut-être il
avait raison peut-être finalement
après tout c'est vrai les vaccins et les
données publiées donnerait peut-être 90
99 % je suis prêt à changer d'avis là
dans cette émission je suis prêt
frontalement à vous dire mais je me suis
trompé c'est vrai il ya quelque chose
qui frappe assez d'arguments sont
corrects mais un petit truc qui va pas
on vous écoute ici les vaccins font que
si les vaccins fonctionne aussi bien
pourquoi astrazeneca sera-t-il obligé de
changer de nom aujourd'hui suite à un
scandale sanitaire
après que ces vaccins et été rappelé et
que le new england journal of medicine
et distingué identifié une maladie
précise qui s'appelle la
thrombocytopénie liés à la vaccination
astrazeneca est que ces vaccinations et
dû être arrêté si c'est là que ça
fonctionne aussi bien pourquoi la
belgique vient-elle aujourd'hui
d'arrêter immédiatement sa campagne de
vaccination avec si ma mémoire est bonne
de vaccins files heures ou johnson &
johnson ça reste à vérifier
pourquoi ces campagnes se sont elles
arrêtées si la vaccination fonctionne
aussi bien avec ses prototypes je le
rappelle ce ne sont pas des vaccins
reconnus universellement comme étant
efficace mais ce sont des prototypes
dont il faut encourager le développement
bien entendu puisque la science avance
par des prototypes mais de là à les
rendre obligatoires c'est un pas assez
avancé je termine donc si jamais la
vaccination fonctionnent comme les
données publiées par les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
eh bien pourquoi est ce que les maldives
qui ont la meilleure couverture
vaccinale au monde ont connu une rechute
absolument foudroyante avec de nouvelles
contaminations notamment de personnes
vaccinées
il faut voir les données en face et ne
surtout pas prendre pour argent comptant
les données qui sont publiés par des
laboratoires dont certains par exemple
fighters ont été condamnés à plus de 5
milliards de dollars d'amendé en
conclusion donc j'aurai beaucoup plus
confiance en l'institut pasteur pour me
donner des chiffres sérieux fiable et
indépendants sur l'immunisation et sur
les résultats de ces prototypes de
vaccins
la recherche se poursuivent bien entendu
mais si on veut dégoûter les gens des
vaccins avis est bien rendue obligatoire
des prototypes sur lesquels la majorité
des données vient des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et on perdra
définitivement la confiance du peuple
alors ça fait beaucoup de questions
auxquelles va tenter de répondre
frédéric lapostolle vos réponses assez à
ces arguments
maintenant la réponse est finalement
relativement simple le syllogisme ne
constitue pas une preuve scientifique on
peut mettre bout à bout des éléments et
ça ne constitue pas une preuve
scientifique donc c'est finalement de
deux bons mots il n'en demeure pas moins
que la prise de décision quand bien même
et personne aujourd'hui je crois ne
méconnaît les effets secondaires qui ont
été rapportés avec le vaccin strazeele
et cas il faut pas oublier que
premièrement il ne pourrait pas être
identifiés sur les études princeps
puisque leur incidence et se compte en
cas par million et que de toute évidence
quand on valide
l'efficacité d'un vaccin ça se fait avec
des dizaines de milliers de patients et
pas avec des millions de patients dont
il était logique de passer à côté
c'est pour ça que dans le développement
d'un médicament après une phase iii qui
montre son efficacité
il ya sept obligatoire une phase iv qui
est de la pharmacovigilance on va
rapporter les effets secondaires et
derrière ça se calcule c'est le bénéfice
pour la population
on a d'un côté une épidémie qui depuis
un an et demi nous pourrit la vie faut
être clair a des conséquences médicales
évidemment mais pas qu'eux a des
conséquences économiques a des
conséquences sociales a des conséquences
sur la scolarisation qui sont absolument
majeur et de l'autre côté on a un vaccin
qui a une efficacité
j'insiste puisque c'est aujourd'hui les
données qui sont disponibles et jusqu'à
ce qu'on en ait produit d'autres je
continuerai reste accroché cette donnée
et ce sera ma conclusion l'arabe le
rapport bénéfices risques est clairement
en faveur du traitement
le problème c'est que ça va être on peut
toujours continuer à dire que ça ne
marche pas et c'est comme ça que ça fait
un an que beaucoup d'équipés ont dépensé
de l'énergie de l'argent à répéter la
même étude par exemple pour montrer que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine fonctionner or
drogue thick euro qui ne fonctionne pas
donc on peut continuer à faire la même
chose on obtiendra le même résultat
aujourd'hui les données disponibles ont
montré que le vaccin n'est vaccin
protégeait à plus de 90% sur les formes
graves et pour s'en sortir
malheureusement jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il n'y a rien d'autre qui
fonctionne merci beaucoup en tout cas
tous les deux on a bien entendu vos
arguments frédéric lapostolle idriss
aberkane d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france et on l'a appris tout à
leur côté éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer a annoncé le déblocage
d'une enveloppe de 700 millions d'euros
pour 2022 un budget qui permettra la
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants et coûté une enveloppe de
700 millions d'euros sera dédié aux
revalorisations
il y à 100 millions d'euros qui
permettront la montée en puissance des
mesures déjà décidées en 2021 400
millions d'euros pour mettre en oeuvre
les nouveaux engagements avec un travail
avec les représentants des personnels
qui se déroulera tout au long du mois de
juin pour prendre les décisions
adéquates notamment de répartition de la
façon dont nos répartition c'est 400
millions d'euros en particulier nous
avons toujours souhaité et revaloriser
les plus jeunes puisque c'est là où le
constations le plus grand retard avec un
objectif sur une base pluriannuelle qui
est d'arriver à ce que dans d'ici
quelques années
et avant 2025 eh bien il n'y ait plus un
seul professeur qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros par mois
dans notre système scolaire après ces
premières augmentations devraient être
versés à la fin du mois mais la nouvelle
n'a pas convaincu les syndicats coûte
400 millions c'est extrêmement faible ce
n'est absolument pas à la hauteur de la
situation
surtout pour un ministre qui s'est
targué dès son entrée en fonction d'une
revalorisation historique
là c'est vraiment des mesurettes c'est
beaucoup de bruit pour rien ce n'est pas
zéro
on ne va pas cracher dessus mais c'est
tout de même assez limité au vu du
nombre d'agents du ministère et au vu du
retard pris en matière salariale pour
nous c'était un moyen de montrer le
soutien qu'on pouvait apporter aux
personnels de l'éducation nationale qui
a fait preuve d'un trait
grand engagement pendant la crise
sanitaire on a montré à quel point on a
réussi à tenir la baraque
c'est une vraie occasion manquée on est
très loin de ce qu attend les
enseignants ça ne va pas assez loin
ce ne sont pas des annonces qui vont
révolutionner le métier avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
aides publiques à la presse et le
ministère de la culture publié en toute
transparence les montants accordés
ces chiffres ne sont désormais plus
divulguer depuis trois ans et puis nous
évoquerons laquelle la nouvelle
calédonie avant la troisième et dernière
consultation sur l'indépendance prévu
d'ici octobre 2022 exécutif réuni les
élus de l'archipel pour étudier les
scénarios du oui et du non reste élevé
[Musique]
ems a exhorté certains pays africains à
ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique non une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
ces bacs celle là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument importants ainsi que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers que
ça soit le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique
du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener la générale de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
m
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livre l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oublié parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il ya quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la dictée pour tous ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes hostiles
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse avec
difficile
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance vous avez choisi le jour à
ba et là on est alors je suis arrivé en
2005 pour étudier dernière poche il en
profiter en 2011 le monde manque pas un
petit peu non ah oui et c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne sors pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge et ans
et demi vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france les aides fournies par l'état
à la presse une pratique ancienne dont
on parle pourtant peu qui vise à
soutenir économiquement les médias de
presse écrite afin de les moderniser de
leur permettre de distribuer leurs
journaux sauf que ces aides sont opaques
à tel point qu'il est difficile de
savoir qui en bénéficient réellement le
site d'investigation la lettre a a
publié des informations que nous
détaille thomas bonnet combien touchent
les titres de presse de la part de
l'état c'est une question à laquelle il
est malheureusement très difficile de
répondre
malgré l'opacité qui règne sur le sujet
le site d'investigation la lettre a
réussi à accéder à des données datant de
on y découvre des chiffres fluctuent en
rendant leur analyse délicate en 2019 en
tout cas 225 millions d'euros d'argent
public ont été attribuées sous la forme
d' aide directe à la presse des aides
visant officiellement à soutenir la
modernisation la distribution ou encore
l'innovation
parmi les titres qui reçoivent le plus
on retrouve le parisien aujourd'hui en
france qui se taille la part du lion
avec 12,6 millions d'euros en 2019
suivent le figaro 6 7 millions d'euros
et le monde 5,6 millions quels sont les
critères qui explique une telle
différence entre les journaux aucune
idée en revanche il semblerait que cela
ne soit pas indexé sur les chiffres de
vente des titres de presse on notera
aussi le budget alloué à la fp
bénéficiaires de cette subvention au
total pour un montant de 124 5 millions
d'euros des chiffres à manier avec
précaution car et diffère selon les
documents c'est en naviguant dans des
milliers de lignes de tableur excel que
les journalistes de la lettre sont
parvenus à ces résultats car malgré la
transparence imposées depuis 2012
la publication officielle de ces
montants cet arrêté en 2010 est
peut-être poussé en ce sens par les
principaux acteurs du secteur roselyne
bachelot la ministre de la culture s'est
opposée récemment à cette diffusion est
paradoxalement l'eau
cité qui entoure ces chiffres ne fait
que renforcer la défiance à l'égard de
ses titres de presse c'est d'ailleurs ce
que dénonce le syndicat de la presse
d'information indépendante en ligne
demandant davantage de transparence
l'organisation questionne aussi la
pertinence de la distribution étatique
des subventions le montant des et
directe de 2019 avantage de manière
totalement disproportionnée quelques
médias aux dépens de tous les autres
l'exemple le plus emblématique et le
montant de 16,8 millions d'euros
accordés aux seuls groupes lvmh qui
capte à lui seul près d'un cinquième des
aides directes
lvmh propriétaire de titres comme le
parisien et dont le patron bernard
arnault a été pendant quelques instants
l'homme le plus riche de la planète lui
qui est aussi accessoirement approche du
président de la république des
parlementaires tentent de remettre à
plat le procédé des aides directes à la
presse au-delà de cet aspect c'est plus
généralement le financement des médias
qui peut poser question
avec des difficultés croissantes
accentuée pendant la pandémie
le secteur est sinistré et les
partenariats noués ci et là avec des
géants américains du numérique ne semble
pas être une solution pérenne libération
expliqué ainsi il ya quelques mois avoir
cessé sa collaboration avec facebook
pour sa plateforme de fact checking
mettant en avant son indépendance
éditoriale
dans un secteur qui perd chaque année la
confiance de ses lecteurs auditeurs et
téléspectateurs
les questions de financement et
d'indépendance éditoriale semble en tout
cas inévitable pour tenter de renouer un
lien distendu
1 pour en parler nous sommes avec eux de
beaufreton délégué général de
l'association contribuables associés
bonsoir de beaux photo merci d'être avec
nous c'est une pratique ancienne on
vient de le voir et pourtant on en parle
peu comment expliquer ce manque de
transparence selon vous il s'agit quand
même d'argent public bonsoir tout
d'abord elle aurait effectivement
lorsqu'il s'agit de subventions il ya la
plus grande opacité en france d'ailleurs
ça ne concerne pas que les aides à la
presse on le retrouve dans les
associations les syndicats qui sont eux
aussi ultra subventionnés et sont des
pratiques qui existent depuis des années
et qui je pense au départ partait d'une
bonne intention qui est elle a pris la
pluralité
d des voix qui pouvait s'élever en
france et qui petit à petit sont devenus
ces aides de plus en plus importante
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui ça atteint
des dizaines de millions et on se rend
bien compte que personne ne sait
finalement comment ces aides sont
attribuées et encore moins le
contribuable parce que lorsque vous êtes
contribuables finalement vous payez pour
des médias et vous n'avez pas fait tel
ou tel choix et on se retrouve nous dans
une situation de prise d'otage et c'est
extrêmement opaque est très désagréable
et je suis bien d'accord avec vous c'est
ce que l'on demande c'est contré
l'associé depuis des années c'est à la
fois une publication officielle des
aides mais également des moyens
d'obtention parce que il ya aucune
grille de lecture et on comprend pas
pourquoi effectivement par exemple le
parisien à quasiment 16 millions d'euros
et puis d'autres titres n'ont que
quelques millions alors à ce moment là
vous nous expliquer pourquoi les puits
qui décide
justement c'était ma question prochaine
dont vous dites qu'on ne sais pas sur
quels critères sont choisis ces titres
de presse parce que si on vous suit bien
le parisien appartient à lvmh qui ont
glané pas démunis de moyens alors que
peut-être que certaines certains organes
de presse peut-être moins subventionnés
en tout cas moins riches n'obtiennent
pas des subventions ça ça veut dire ça
alors ce que j'imagine quand même c'est
que il doit y avoir une sorte de clé de
répartition qui doit être
proportionnelle finalement au nombre de
lecteurs mais encore faudrait-il le
vérifier en forme tous les cas
officiellement sam n'est pas affichée ça
n'est pas expliquée mais je pense que
c'est ça doit être ça ce qui revient à
une forme de représentative vitae mais
le danger de cette pratique si c'est
bien celle ci qui retenu pour attribuer
de l'argent public et je rappelle quand
même que chaque euro versé par l'état
est un euro payé par le contribuable et
donc les contribuables on a un droit de
regard mais au-delà de ça
si c'était la clé de répartition ça veut
dire que finalement plus un média à un
nombre important de lecteurs ou
d'auditeurs autres spectateurs parce que
ça va aussi
d'autres médias un type la télévision
etc et bien finalement creuse l'écart
entre les grands médias nationaux et les
petits médias locaux entre guillemets
même s'il ya pas de petits médias et on
peut pas s'empêcher de penser que
derrière ces grands médias et bien
évidemment il ya toujours la main
nourricière et que lorsque vous recevez
des subventions forcément vous êtes
tentés d'être plus indulgent avec ceux
qui vous verse les les subventions en
tous les cas on peut le penser
et d'ailleurs nous chez contribué
associés nous sommes une association loi
1901 ne percevons aucune subvention
d'argent public c'est interdit par nos
statuts très volontairement
déontologiquement pour justement avoir
une totale liberté de ton et pour qu'à
aucun moment ni l'état ni des élus
puissent se servir au travers de la
subvention d'un moyen de faire pression
pour nous de faire passer des messages
et je peux pas m'empêcher en tant que
praticien entre guillemets de me dire
que dans certains médias est bien
effectivement il peut y avoir de
l'indulgence quand vous percevez des
millions d'euros vous dites les
contribuables geste triptans un droit de
regard
est ce que ce sont eux qui payent est-ce
que vous avez déjà tenté de demander des
comptes au ministère de la culture sur
ces subventions et si oui que vous
attend répondu c'est l'omerta complète
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes noyé dans
dans des dédales administratifs ou vous
n'arrivez jamais à voir le bon
interlocuteur
et comme vous le savez dans
l'administration française personne
n'est responsable
alors on a des effectifs pléthoriques
dans l'administration mais personne
n'est responsable tant et si bien que
vous n'arrivez jamais avoir de réponse
d'ailleurs c'est le grand drame
aujourd'hui des dépenses publiques en
france c'est que l'information est très
peu diffusé aux citoyens parce que je
pense qu'il reste beaucoup de gens dans
la rue si c'était le cas et nous chez
contribué associés alors que pourtant
représente 350 mille membres
on a le plus grand mal effectivement
avoir des données publiques de ce type
je l'observais également dans d'autres
domaines en ce moment nous nous créons
un argus des départements et des régions
pour vérifier le niveau de dépenses des
départements et des régions
eh bien on a la plus grande difficulté
obtenir la comptabilité des départements
et des régions de france
alors qu'on est en période pré
électorale puisque les élections sur le
mois prochain
et là encore on a été obligé de servir
de saisir le service administratif de la
cada une sorte de police des polices qui
vient
théoriquement imposées aux collectivités
autres de fournir des comptes
eh bien on arrive malgré la kaaba
toujours pas obtenir ce chiffre
c'est dire c'est dire en france à quel
point la dépense publique c'est l'omerta
la plus complète et quand on a 60 2 % de
dépenses publiques du pib comme c'est le
cas en ce moment
et bien si on veut que les français qui
payent des impôts continuent à payer des
impôts eh bien l'état ferait bien d'être
transparent et de nous expliquer comment
et dépenser notre argent
merci à eux 2 beaufreton délégué général
de l'association contribuables associés
merci à vous et dans le reste de
l'actualité
toujours en france les inégalités
médical de plus en plus forte sur le
territoire la clé sanitaire encore
augmenter les disparités pour l'accès
aux soins
en moyenne on dénombre 150 et un médecin
généraliste pour 100000 habitants et
mais les écarts d'un territoire un autre
peuvent être très importants reporter
job au reportage dans l'aisne et de la
seine-et-marne où les communes tentent
de pallier le manque de service médical
avec renault parquet et maxime a bola
11%
ils sont 11% des français à vivre dans
une zone en pénurie de services médicaux
un constat qui se ressent davantage dans
les campagnes de l'hexagone c'est le cas
notamment à pinon dans l'aisne la
commune de 1780 habitants située
pourtant à seulement une heure et quart
de paris a beaucoup de peine à attirer
des médecins il ya quelques années
encore pinon compter deux médecins ces
deux médecins sont partis au fur et à
mesure en retraite
et on a essayé déjà un moment de trouver
un médecin
étrangers mais qui n'est pas resté
longtemps ça n'a pas été un succès on a
fait venir deux médecins adjoint ils
sont restés un peu plus d'un an et
ensuite ils sont partis voilà et donc là
ça fait plus d'un an et demi presque
qu'on est fort médecin pourtant ce n'est
pas la demande qui manquent
avec plus d'un millier de patients à
pinon loin d'être laissé à l'abandon par
la mairie au contraire la commune a
investi en achetant cet ancien salon de
coiffure pour le transformer en cabinet
médical
elle se dit également prête à aider à
l'installation des futurs candidats tout
comme l' agence régionale de santé qui
propose des aides pouvant avoisiner les
50 mille euros par mois matériel est à
disposition effectivement tout ce qui
est partie informatique et présent on
peut les aider effectivement sur des
peut-être sur des parties année as
administratif ce n'est pas à exclure
tout ce qui est terminal carte vitale
tout est à disposition à une centaine de
kilomètres de là la ville de montereau
en seine-et-marne s'est elle aussi
retrouvés en pénurie alors la commune a
créé un pôle de santé municipal en
salariant ses propres médecins et pour
répondre à la demande croissante des
quelques 20 mille habitants une borne de
téléconsultation a été installé quant à
réussir ça lui fait main grâce à des
appareils présents sur la borne le
malade peut s'auto ou sculptées et voir
ses résultats apparaître directement sur
l'écran pour le maire de montereau
l'objectif de ce pôle est de répondre à
une demande sans surcharger le budget de
la ville
nous allons créer un budget annexe en
dehors du budget purement municipal le
principe pour nous évidemment d'arriver
à l'équilibré de ce service pour qu'il
apporte un service supplémentaire aux
habitants de la commune et du territoire
mais qui ne grève pas le budget de la
commune et ce pôle médical municipal est
ouvert depuis un an et demi depuis un an
et demi
nous sommes à l'équilibré budgétaire en
france dans les zones en pénurie de
médecins
les habitants ne bénéficient en moyenne
que
2,5 consultations par an jean castex
recevait aujourd'hui des responsables
politiques de nouvelle-calédonie il
s'agit du premier rendez vous d'une
semaine de discussions voulues par le
gouvernement sur l'accord de nouméa un
sommet décisif en vue d'un troisième
référendum sur l'indépendance du
territoire ultramarin ont fait le point
en images après le deuxième référendum
sur l'indépendance de la nouvelle
calédonie en octobre 2020 marqué par une
victoire du non moins large que lors du
premier scrutin le ministre d outre-mer
sébastien lecornu a mené des réunions
avec les indépendantistes d'un côté et
les loyalistes de l'autre mais les
personnalités politiques des deux bords
n'ont jamais souhaité se rencontrer
l'union nationale pour l'indépendance a
décidé de ne pas répondre à l'invitation
du gouvernement à cette semaine de
discussions mais aurait annoncé sa venue
à paris en juillet
sébastien lecornu a malgré tout laissé
la porte ouverte et déclaré mercredi que
les formations politiques qui le
souhaitaient pouvaient participer aux
échanges à distance en invitant les
indépendantistes et les loyalistes
matignon a l'intention de relancer le
dialogue dans un communiqué l'exécutif a
reconnu que cette mission je cite ne
serait pas facile
il compte sur la capacité des différents
acteurs à sortir de leur posture pour
aller réellement au fond des échanges
ce sommet doit permettre d'organiser le
troisième et dernier référendum prévu
par l'accord de nouméa
d'ici à octobre 2022 et de travailler
sur toutes les conséquences d'un oui ou
d'un an
jeudi et vendredi les politiques
calédoniens assisteront à des
présentations de travaux menés par
l'état pour évaluer les deux issues
possibles et leur impact sur l'aspect
juridique économique financier ainsi que
les politiques publiques du quotidien et
l'exercice des compétences régaliennes
des discussions plus politiques auront
lieu lundi et mardi prochains l'enjeu
majeur pour le gouvernement sera de
parvenir à un maintien du dialogue dans
la durée mardi devant l'assemblée
nationale
sébastien lecornu a exprimé la volonté
de l'exécutif de sortir du choix un peu
obscur et stérile entre le oui et le non
est d'essayer de trouver un nouveau
chemin qui je cite permettent la paix et
le développement prospère de la nouvelle
calédonie et par an par les noces en
avait qui se met kurtovitch historien
spécialiste de la nouvelle-calédonie
contemporaine bonsoir il se met vite
merci d'être avec nous premières
journées dont deux de rencontre entre
jean castex sr responsables politiques
de nouvelle-calédonie leçon reçue
pendant une semaine ça montre
l'importance que revêt ce dossier
qu'elle ait de lien pour le gouvernement
français
oui à chaque fois les réunions à paris
sont très importants ils sont ce qu elle
est souvent ans au sommet le premier
ministre parfois le président de la
république et celle ci le sont
particulièrement puisqu'il s'agit
finalement de la dernière étape de la
sortie de l'accord de nouméa qui a
maintenant plus de vingt ans puisque
nous sommes face au troisième référendum
qui doit décider si oui ou non la
nouvelle calédonie va vers la pleine
souveraineté
alors que peut-on attendre de cette
semaine de discussions est ce que le
gouvernement peut renouer le dialogue
entre indépendantistes et loyalistes
toujours possible oui le le dialogue n'a
pas vraiment cessé il a été renoué il y
a près de six mois lorsque monsieur le
cornu est venu à nouméa il a dû
d'ailleurs faire une quarantaine il a
réuni les principaux partis politiques
dans sur un îlot qui s'appelle le brédou
on appelle ça le groupe le pré ndour et
les échanges ont pu être avancé et on
est là dans une continuité à paris mais
une continuité avec des difficultés
nouvelles qui sont dues à la conjoncture
politique et économique en nouvelle
calédonie c'est s'il gagne et moi on
vous dit le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu ça dépend pour qui
par exemple l'union nationale pour
l'indépendance à lalinde et de courants
du fln et qui s annonçait qu'elle ne
répondrait pas cette invitation du
gouvernement pour quelles raisons oui en
fait les indépendantistes traverse une
mauvaise passe
comme a dit l'un d'eux ils ne se parlent
même plus alors qu'ils devraient se
parler puisqu'ils ont la majorité dans
le gouvernement élu et ils n'arrivent
pas à s'entendre sur une politique
commune au sein de ce gouvernement et
une répartition des responsabilités donc
nous sommes avec un gouvernement qui
expédie les affaires courantes
ensuite de ça il y a eu des événements
violents dans la de cette année sur
terre coutumière que ce soit sur la
grande terre aux îles loyauté
il y a eu les difficultés liées à la
reprise de de l'usiné de vale dans le
sud
malgré que les indépendantistes étaient
des unis sur cette question il y a eu
des des conflits des difficultés entre
les salariés de l'usiné et l'extérieur
et ensuite la politique minière en
province nord et fait l'objet de
discussions de contestation entre les
deux principaux partis indépendantistes
ce qui fait que ça à traiter ça a créé
un contexte qui a fait que l'uni panika
a préféré ne pas venir à paris plus le
fait que le document de l'état apparu
quand même nécessaire de prendre plus de
temps pour y répondre et pour en
discuter de la part de l'uni palika et
de l'union progressiste mélanésienne
alors lors des derniers référendum
les indépendantistes étaient largement
majoritaires et puis ça s'est un petit
peu serré
les lors des dernières consultations est
ce qu on peut clairement parler
aujourd'hui de moments charnières ada
proche de cette troisième consultation
sur l'indépendance
oui le moment est charnière parce que
monsieur le cornu a innové en somme
en demandant l'administration de l'état
de travailler dans le détail sur les
conséquences mais pour l'état d'une
accession à l'indépendance je vais dire
classique de la nouvelle calédonie et
c'est ce que vont faire les élus
calédoniens à paris ils vont balayer
secteur par secteur et aussi thème par
thème la monnaie le droit
le nickel toutes les conséquences pour
le pays d'une accession à la pleine
souveraineté qui est finalement la
question principale qui est posée au
référendum donc là cet aspect tour ce
référendum pour ce travail politique est
plus important que pour les deux
premiers et on le doit à monsieur
lecornu clairement dans l'hypothèse de
l'indépendance est ce que le nouvel état
cherchera à conclure des traités
notamment de partenariats d'associations
vous venez de le citer il ya d'énormes
richesses en nouvelle calédonie et c'est
compliqué on imagine pour le
gouvernement français dit relancer
aujourd'hui c'est une question qui qui
est débattue ce qui se passe c'est que
les indépendantistes ont toujours dit
qu'il y aurait un partenariat privilégié
avec la france mais la question c'est de
savoir si les exclusives le degré de
cette exclusivité et la profondeur de ce
partenariat c'est ça fait l'objet
d'ailleurs de plusieurs questions que
l'état pose au mouvement indépendantiste
merci beaucoup il se met kurtovitch
d'avoir été avec nous lors de sectes
première journée donc de rencontre entre
jean castex et les responsables
politiques de nouvelle zélande dans le
reste
dans le reste de l'actualité jour de
vote en syrie place en ce moment même au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle un scrutin ni libre ni
est juste selon les capitales
occidentales
un jugement qui ne vaut rien selon le
président sortant bachar el assad
ce dernier brigue un quatrième mandat
grâce d'aia bachar al assad ou son
fauteuil présidentiel
un quatrième mandat après 21 ans à la
tête du pays
une élection totalement rejeté par les
pays occidentaux qui estiment que les
dés sont joués d'avancé
l'échec à adopter une nouvelle
constitution est la preuve que la
soi-disant élections du 26 mai sera une
imposture
la france ne reconnaîtra aucune validité
aux élections prévues par le régime
fermé
et pourtant la syrie a convié des
parlementaires d'une quinzaine de pays
parmi eux des observateurs iraniens
russes chinois algérien vénézuéliens ou
encore cubain moscou membre ou du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu déplore la
position occidentale et dénonce une
ingérence
il est désolant de voir que certains
pays sont hostiles à l'idée même de
l'élection à venir et se sont déjà à thé
de la déclaré illégitime
c'est une ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures de la syrie inacceptable et
contraire aux normes existantes du droit
international durant cette campagne 51
candidats dont sept femmes ont
officiellement déposé leur candidature
seuls deux ont été retenus pour la
population la priorité et les règlements
de la crise économique aussi bien pour
les syriens vivant sur place qu'à
l'étranger
l'économie bien sûr est la plus grande
préoccupation de tous les syriens
surtout en ce qui concerne l'inflation
le taux de change de la livre syrienne
par rapport au dollar américain a baissé
ces jours ci ce qui est un bon signe si
je me souviens bien les slogans des
candidats visaient à apporter de
l'espoir au pays ce qui renforce notre
confiance dans l'amélioration de nos
conditions de vie
cela pourrait également encourager les
diplômés à trouver de bons emplois
aujourd'hui nous sommes venus ici pour
notre avenir nous sommes donnés pour
dire que notre voie est libre et que
nous choisissons ceux qui nous
représentent
afin de les accompagner dans la
construction de ce beau pays nous sommes
des décideurs avec toute liberté et
libre arbitre pour choisir qui nous
représenteront en vue que les radars à
morton millimes celles non je suis ici
pour participer à ce scrutin car tout
syriens résidant à l'étranger doit
participer à ce devoir
c'est la moindre des choses nous sommes
venus prouver que nous avons encore
confiance que nous sommes en sécurité et
que la syrie est en cours de
reconstruction et de développement
c'est la moindre des choses après dix
ans de guerre des défis majeurs pour le
futur président car cette élection
intervient dans un contexte de fortes
tensions avec une crise humanitaire et
une crise économique fortement aggravée
par la pandémie de kobe 19 après dix ans
de conflit des centaines de milliers de
morts et de déplacés
l'objectif semble désormais la
reconstruction du pays
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la situation
sanitaire outre-manche qui inquiète le
nom de contamination du var hier indiens
exposés royaume et pourtant le pays le
plus vaccinée d'europe et puis nous
parlerons des très grandes entreprises
françaises qui ont pu profiter des aides
publiques massives de l'état durant la
peau les endémies
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on en beaucoup
d'endroits beaucoup d'angoissé autres
les équipes de reprendre un rythme avec
en plus des restrictions qui sont
délicates pour travailler correctement
les projections de croissance etc c'est
exceptionnel
on a eu des doutes qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça il va
falloir quand même avoir une vision de
relance il vient d'accompagner un peu
plus longue on navigue presque un petit
peu a vu quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable que ça fasse
beaucoup de dégâts parce qu'on va avoir
un deuxième coup fatal de rien et un
autre comme film en septembre octobre
serait dramatique pour la profession et
moralement de terribles qu'on nous vend
du rêve et malheureusement ça se
transforme vite en cauchemar
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé les violences de
la maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous un peu long
des pratiques professionnelles
protectrice la justice à sa part dans
cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
deux termes banlieue voire le top 6 tc
forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que les
médias ont un regard on va dire assez
particulier des banlieues et qui dérange
aujourd'hui et en donne cette impression
de la banlieue ça se résoudrait cas des
jeunes violents contre une police qui
serait son travail c'est plus compliqué
que ça on est français on est fiers de
vivre dans ces quartiers même s'il ya
des difficultés est la moindre des
choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte canton quand on participe à la
vie de la société et malheureusement il
n'y a pas cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse keith kg politique fort pour les
gens mais sans les gens c'est à dire qui
donne cette impression de faire de
vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
faux
[Musique]
vous
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage une montagne de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
21h08 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 26 mai
isolation obligatoire pour les voyageurs
en provenance du royaume uni
déclarations de gabriella talent
aujourd'hui à l'issue du conseil des
ministres
une mesure déjà adoptée par l'allemagne
et qui illustre les craintes suscitées
par le variant indien
autrement justement l'inquiétude grandit
le nombre de contaminations variés
indien explosé augmentant de 160% cours
de la semaine écoulée selon le guardian
de quoi interroger puisque l'on hume uni
est le pays européen le plus vaccinée
face à ces chiffres le gouvernement
johnson est accusé d'avoir tardé à
prendre des mesures pour restreindre
l'arrivée de personnes en provenance
d'inde à minsk accusent la france de
piraterie aérienne pour avoir refusé son
espace aérien à un avion en belarus
effectuant une liaison minsk barcelone
et forçant à faire demi tour
trois jours après le détournement d'un
avion de ligne à la suite duquel
l'opposant a été arrêté alexandre
loukachenko affirmant que son pays a agi
légalement aucune raison de ne pas le
parent selon moscou à l'onu l'europe et
les etats-unis demandent une enquête
urgente de l'organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale
et justement le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies qui se réunit également
pour examiner la situation au mali en
cause l'arrestation du président de la
transition et de son premier ministre
par les militaires tous deux ont
démissionné selon des sources militaires
et diplomatiques la communauté
internationale appelle à leur libération
[Musique]
la circulation d'épidémies et de moins
en moins actives en france mais n'est
pas pour autant sous contrôle les taux
d'incidence reste un tout est levé sur
tout le territoire
c'est dans ce contexte de fragile des
crues que l'académie de médecine s'est
prononcé pour la vaccination obligatoire
relançant les débats un sujet
inflammable dans un pays réputé pour
compter de nombreux sceptiques les
précisions de david khalifa et bien
réactions plutôt négatives 1 suite à
cette déclaration de patrick berche de
nombreux spécialistes sont montés au
créneau car on se souvient que les
français étaient déjà plutôt sceptique
vis-à-vis de cette vaccination jean paul
hamon le président d'honneur de la
fédération des médecins de france ne
veut surtout pas brusquer les français à
du côté est de la rs on préconise de la
patience et goûter
ce n'est pas le moment de braquer les
gens inutilement on commence à avoir
suffisamment de doses pour vacciner les
gens laissons faire
on verra bien au mois de septembre
octobre dans quelle situation sera mais
parti comme c'est parti on est parti
pour vacciner près de 10 millions de
personnes par mois il faut être patient
pour l'instant plein de gens veulent se
faire vacciner et on n'a pas assez de
vaccins
les rendez vous ne sont pas faciles à
obtenir le jour où tous ceux qui
voulaient se faire vacciner se sont fait
vacciner et qu'on voit un frein dans la
campagne de vaccination liés à
l'adhésion
peut-être qu'on pourra se poser la
question rendre un vaccin obligatoire
peut être un frein à l'adhésion
vaccinale vous savez comment sont les
français
il suffit de leur dire que quelque chose
est obligatoire pour qu'ils imaginent
quelque chose de louche derrière pour
l'académie de médecine âge leur appel à
s'éloigner le plus sûr a pour atteindre
à l'immunité et collective ce qui
signifie 90% de la population à vacciner
le terme obligations a subjugué s
certains politiques c'est le cas de
florian philippot le leader adea
patriotes qui appelle les français à se
révolter sur twitter regarder voilà nous
y sommes
l'académie de médecine préconise de
rendre obligatoire le vaccin pour de
nombreuses catégories de français et de
vacciner enfants et adolescents la
terreur cofidis
franchi une nouvelle étape réveillons
nous c'est l'une des rares réactions
politiques qu'on a pu observer sur les
réseaux sociaux peu d'élus à souhaite
remettre ce sujet sur la table 1 du côté
de l'opposition comme elle du côté de la
majorité car cette question considérée
comme de santé publique un parent à
l'académie de médecine restent très
sensibles à savoir que l'exécutif s'est
déjà exprimé sur cette hypothèse
emmanuel macron la semaine dernière
affirmé lui-même que la vie de chacun le
respect de la vie de chacun prédomine je
préfère marcher par la conviction ans
selon ses mots mais gabriel attal elle
reste lui a plu à des vases if cet après
midi le porte parole du gouvernement a
dit entendre ces recommandations de
l'académie de médecine
ce sont des études que nous regardons
mais notre objectif reste de vacciner
ceux qui le souhaitent pour le moment on
le rappelle que dans ce contexte
d'urgence sanitaire tout reste possible
mais nul doute que cette décision
rendrait furieux les anti vaccins qui
sont au nombre de 20 % selon elle les
derniers chiffres annoncés et autres
mangent dépistage massif à londres après
l'arrêt détection de cas de variants
indien le gouvernement britannique qui
craint une reprise de l'épidémie a pris
la décision de restreindre la
circulation des londoniens dans certains
quartiers de la ville depuis vendredi
pour limiter la propagation du variant
indien de son côté l'organisation
mondiale de la santé alerte et ce matin
avoir détecté se mariant dans 53
territoire julien dureau
le royaume uni ne voit pas encore tout à
fait le bout du tunnel du coc vite 19
après la mise en oeuvre d'un
déconfinement progressif
entamée dès la mi-avril le pays
s'inquiètent désormais de la montée du
variant indien responsable de la
deuxième vague meurtrière qui frappe
actuellement l'inde
ils menacent un peu plus chaque jour le
royaume uni selon lagence public health
england 3424 cas confirmés ont été
comptabilisés le 20 mai contre 1313 le
13 mai soit une hausse de 160% la
situation interroge en europe
en allemagne l'institut de veille
sanitaire robert koch a même placé le
pays comme une zone à haut risque au
même titre que onze états d'asie
d'afrique et d'amérique
berlin a donc réagi en restreignant les
échanges avec le royaume-uni imposant du
coup une quarantaine aux voyageurs venus
de son sol
quant à la france un isolement
obligatoire est aussi prévue pour ces
mêmes voyageurs je veux rappeler que la
france est un pays qui a pris très peu
des mesures très fortes de contrôles à
ses frontières notamment été frontières
des pays extérieurs à l'union européenne
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un cadre très
puissant qui s'applique donc y compris
au royaume uni avec l'autorisation pour
venir en france pour les personnes qui
sont de nationalité française
avec des motifs impérieux pour se
déplacer ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
ya une nouvelle donne avec le
développement du variant 10 indiens au
royaume-uni que l'allemagne a annoncé il
ya quelques heures ou quelques jours des
mesures supplémentaires notamment en
termes d'isolement pour les personnes
qui proviennent du royaume uni et que la
france va prendre des mesures semblables
et donc mettre en place un isolement
obligatoire pour les personnes qui
viendraient du royaume uni une situation
inconfortable que le royaume uni aurait
semble-t-il pu éviter le pays est en
effet accusé d'avoir tardé à prendre des
dispositions sur les voyageurs en
provenance d'inde
de plus le payer a massivement été
vaccinés avec astrazeneca efficace à
seulement 60 % face aux variants une
stratégie vaccinale qui n'aidera pas le
payer à sortir la tête de l'eau
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis le royaume-uni avec bharat
banques gagnent un expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
narrateur bancaire merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on le
rappelle un pays le plus vacciner
d'europe pourquoi le royaume uni est il
autant touchés par le variant indien
qu'est ce que ça dit de gouttes musée
est bonne nouvelle c'est que le
programme d'immunisation au royaume uni
est couronnée de succès en majorité cela
ne signifie cependant pas que la
totalité de la population est vaccinée
ce variant par exemple qui vient d'inde
et plus contaminant et donc ils trop
flux des poches de personnes non
immunisées qu'il contamine l'âge
dans la majorité des cas se trouvaient
dans des endroits par le ter est
d'ailleurs une large partie de la
population vient d'inde du pakistan du
bangladesh où d'autres régions
similaires
c'est là que le vaccin a été repéré
c'est là qu'on trouve un nombre
grandissant de cas aux vins terme et 55
7% de la population au royaume uni avait
reçu une première dose du vaccin
ça veut dire ce que vous êtes en train
de nous expliquer que les nouveaux
contaminés sont à chercher plutôt dans
la partie non vaccinés en tout cas de la
deuxième dose est pas dedans l'ineffable
inefficacité probable
des vaccins le vaccin est très efficace
contre le variant de tenues c'est la
bonne nouvelle
l'ès 10 cause et variant et environnants
de plus la seule chose qui est certaine
concernant ce variant venus d'inde c'est
qu'il est plus contagieux lorsqu'on a
reçu une seule dose du vaccin oms ne
toujours vulnérable et on risque d'être
contaminé par ce que le niveau maximal
de protection intervient après deux
doses de vaccin
lescoules de personnes notamment parmi
elles les plus jeunes peuvent encore
être vaccinés et s'ils se trouvent dans
les régions où le virus circule alors il
est très facile pour eux d'être infectés
il ya aussi une distinction entre les
vaccins parce que vous au royaume uni
vous avez deux vaccins le viseur et
beaucoup d'astrazeneca
il semblerait que ce dernier soit un peu
moins efficace contre le variant indien
c'est exact mais on ne paye pas et
luxueux les paquets
on peut dire que l'efficacité de father
et quelques pourcents points de
pourcentage de plus que l'efficacité de
astrazeneca
mais les deux vaccins fonctionne très
bien les deux vaccins protègent et les
deux vaccins à remplissent leurs
objectifs
c'est à dire qu'ils produisent une
mémoire immunitaire et empêche les
formes graves de la maladie
si je n'étais pas vacciner alors je
prendrai le premier vaccin disponible
qu'il s'agisse d'astrazeneca ou de
pfizer ils sont tous les deux fikin s'il
ya aussi la question de la deuxième dose
on rappelle que elle a été rallongée au
royaume uni au tout départ de la
campagne de vaccination pour vacciner
plus est ce que on se rend compte que
c'est
une erreur de ce point de vue là parce
que finalement le bariant indien va plus
vite que le temps de se vacciner non à
donington à genève ans par woods to
protect souhaitons protéger la
population et la première dose protège
empêche le développement des formes les
plus graves de la maladie et le décès
cette stratégie consistant à distribuer
d'abord les premières doses pu à
retarder la seconde était une bonne
décision au niveau scientifique
d'ailleurs maintenant nous avons un
stock important de vaccins de pfizer de
moderna d'astrazeneca et nous avons
changé
cette stratégie nous avons modifié
l'intervalle qui est passé de 12
semaines à 8 semaines entre les deux
doses les intervalles de 12 semaines
était tout à fait correcte car
l'objectif était de tuer autant de
personnes que possible aussi rapidement
que possible
maintenant que nous avons astrazeneca
pfizer et moderna on peut réduire cet
intervalle de faire passer de 12
semaines à huit semaines
la dernière fois que je vous ai eu en
interview on avait commenté la décision
du gouvernement britannique de fermer un
petit peu tardivement ses frontières
avec justement l'inde est ce que c'était
ça pour le coup une erreur au yes we
might and magic spells lakhmatov
beaucoup d'experts dont moi-même et
disions que les critères de fermeture
des frontières
les critères pour placer un pays sur la
liste rouge n'était pas ne sont toujours
pas claires
c'est clair c'est que le pakistan le
bangladesh qui sont les pays voisins de
l'inde avait des métaux de cadets nombre
de cas plus bas et avec tt est également
sur la liste orange
alors que l'un d'eux y avait tout ce que
qu'a ainsi qu'un autre où il y avait
plus de cas et il y avait un variant
plus contaminés moi qui n'avais pas été
mais tout de suite sur la liste rouge
devient plus tard c'était une erreur et
bien sûr en conséquence le varia le
variant était un portage aux kora et
muse et nous voyons mal dans différents
foyers de contamination et une
augmentation des cas sur place vous avez
peut-être entendu qu'en france on a
ouvert un petit peu le débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire ce que vous
craignez au royaume uni avec ce variant
indien ce que vous constatez même est ce
que ça pourrait être le cas selon vous
en france vous le craignez au yes we can
do you wanna qu'est ce qui arrive au
royaume uni arrivera en france et vice
versa et globaux en plein air
nous sommes sur planète mondialisée il
faut donc faire très attention et
travailler de concert il n'y a aucune
véritable il ya nous devons endiguer la
contamination au niveau mondial
immunization si le royaume uni et très
vacciner et que l'union européenne ait
mal vaccinés alors c'est très mauvais
signe
il faut avoir un taux de vaccination
élevés dans le monde entier pour
protéger le monde entier en même temps
et ensemble merci bar à tapas ocaña
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
au chapitre économique certaines
entreprises du cac 40 ont bénéficié des
aides de l'état comme le prêt garanti ou
le chômage partiel
et pourtant cela n'a pas dissuadé ces
groupes de licencier ou distribuer des
dividendes aux actionnaires dans des
proportions parfois impressionnantes
les explications de katia technique
selon l'observatoire des multinationales
en 2020 les entreprises du cac 40 ont
versé 140 % de leurs profits à leurs
actionnaires
c'est donc plus que ce qu'elles ont
engrangé à là où vont-elles trouver
l'argent est bien dans leur trésorerie
problème c'est qu'elles sont irrigués
par des fonds publics en effet avec la
crise du coville gouvernement français à
distribuer des aides massives pour
soutenir les entreprises grands groupes
inclus mais en retour peu de contrôle ou
de contrepartie ont été exigés le
gouvernement n'a pas demandé par exemple
d'engagement social environnemental ni
même l'arrêt de pratiques d'optimisation
fiscale mais il y avait bien des
garde-fous les grandes entreprises
bénéficiant dette de l'état devait
s'engager à ne pas verser de dividende
en france ou à l'étranger ni de racheter
des actions en 2020 mais cela ne
concernait que les groupes d'au moins
5000 salariés ou dont le chiffre
d'affaires dépassé 1,5 milliard d'euros
en france
les mailles du filet et est donc assez
large mais pour faire le bilan seuls
0,01 % des entreprises du cac 40 ont eu
recours au prêt d'état garantie c'est à
dire le fameux pge mais cela représente
tout de même 12 points 3 % du montant
alloué
renault et air france conforama ou
lagardère pour ne citer qu'eux sont des
entreprises qui ont été aidées et qui
ont pourtant licenciés 27 groupes du cac
40 aurait profité du dispositif du
chômage partiel
malgré cette aide seize ont versé des
dividendes en 2020 et 22 en 2021 soit
80% d'entre elles l'observatoire des
multinationales dans ce dossier a
recensé 60 2500 suppressions d'emplois
dans le monde dont la moitié en france
et bien parmi les entreprises les plus
soutenus certaines ont pourtant
également licencié et pourtant elles ne
sont pas toutes en difficulté bien au
contraire seul
six groupes du cac 40 ont eu des pertes
ont connu des pertes et du côté des
rémunérations la tendance est tout beau
fixe cette dirigeants du cac 40 ont même
augmenté leur rémunération en 2020
malgré la crise du coc vie donc les
grands patrons et les actionnaires ont
su profiter de cet effet d'aubaine
inattendue de la pandémie et pour en
parler nous sommes avec dany langue
économiste membre des économistes
atterrés bonsoir dany langue une hausse
des dividendes donc aux actionnaires
après plus d'une année de pandémie est
ce que ça vous surprend on parle quand
même de 51 milliards d'euros ça fait
beaucoup
c'est beaucoup mais ça ne me surprend
guère parce que c'est dans la logique du
capitalisme financiarisé dans lequel on
est entré maintenant il ya quatre
décennies et dans ce capitalisme
financiarisé
on est dans cette logique de service à
d'actionnaires tout est fait pour verser
le maximum de bénéfices aux actionnaires
tout est fait dans une logique de très
court terme
et cette situation de pandémie ne fait
pas exception on pouvait peut-être
s'attendre assez naïvement à ce que les
entreprises
au vu de la situation se calme sur
l'eure là versement de dividendes aux
actionnaires
mais on est dans la droite ligne de ce
qui se fait au fond depuis quatre
décennies où on demande aux entreprises
de verser des dividendes même si elles
n'ont pas les moyens et de d'assurer des
taux de rentabilité délirant entre 17 et
25 %
c'est pas la première fois qu'on entend
parler de ces situations
j'aimerais rappeler qu'avant la pandémie
certaines grandes entreprises fermer
certaines filiales qui ne rapportaient
que de 12% par an ou du
du 10 % par an et qui était rentable
donc on est dans la droite ligne de
cette logique ça se voit un peu plus
parce qu'effectivement comme l'a très
bien souligné votre journaliste ici on a
de l'argent public qui a été utilisée
pour que les rentiers ça s'accorde un
peu mieux la fête
sauf que là il ya eu carrément 22%
d'augmentation encore plus de
distribution de dividendes que l'année
passée ça peut être très étonnant quand
même en pleine crise sanitaire ça me
dire que ces aides de l'état elles ont
contribué à ce que ça aille aussi bien
pour ses grandes entreprises
ben les aides de l'état ont été
distribués eux sans conditions il
fallait effectivement au vu de la
situation des confinement apporter une
aide de l'état pour éviter
l'effondrement généralisé et d'ailleurs
ce qui m'inquiète
on en a déjà parlé ici sur et retisser
que c'est des prêts garantis et donc que
de ces entreprises n'ont fait que
qu'augmenter landete mais oui à partir
de mon nombril n'est pas de conditions
bien ça profite aussi à des entreprises
qui font ça et qui se font plaisir et et
qui en général d'ailleurs payent
beaucoup moins d'impôts sur les sociétés
que les pme et les pmi le parce qu'elles
savent utiliser toutes les armes fiscale
et tous les avocats
donc effectivement le bon sens voudrait
qu'au vu de la situation
elle se soit calmée mais le bon sens et
la finance sont deux choses extrêmement
différente et là on voit bien le visage
de ce capitalisme financiarisé qui ne
s'intéresse qu'au court terme et qui ne
s'intéressent qu'à l' qu'au versement de
dividendes pour les rentiers ai tout de
même jusqu'à des plans sociaux commenté
dans la presse
c'est un petit peu antinomique autant de
dividendes et ses plans sociaux à ce
moment-là précis les plans sociaux qui
est une manière polie de dire que on va
licencier des gens elle s'en débarrasser
cela permet effectivement de dégager
plus de profits et qui dit plus de
profit de verser des dividendes
supérieurs aux actionnaires voilà on est
dans cette logique où les entreprises ne
sont pas là pour être soutenable et
faire fonctionner leurs activités à long
terme elles sont là pour verser des
dividendes de court terme à leurs
actionnaires
j'aimerais quand même rappeler que je
disais tout à l'heure que ces 17 à 25 %
de rentabilité qu'on demande aux
entreprises alors que pendant les trente
glorieuses où l'économie fonctionnait
beaucoup mieux et où les entreprises
aillent des objectifs à plus long terme
on leur demander de faire du 3% et c'est
normal parce que on leur demandait de
réinvestir de voir les choses à long
terme d'assurer la croissance et
d'assurer l'emploi on a changé que logic
on pensait qu'avec le confinement et la
crise du capitalisme financiarisé les
choses allaient être amené à changer et
puis là on voit une fois plus cette
logique court termiste c'est une logique
peut-être une musique qu'on entend moins
mais mais il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle c'est que cet argent il est
injecté dans l'économie les ces mêmes
actionnaires paye peut-être des impôts
dans les caisses de l'état qui profitait
à la collectivité vous l'admettrez quand
même aussi que ça peut être aussi une
bonne nouvelle pour les français
ben ça dépend quel fond c'est
effectivement pour les rentiers c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais c'est pas les
rentiers qui font fonctionner une
économie ce sont ce sont les
travailleurs en premier lieu c'est à
dire ceux qui produisent de la richesse
et puis ce sont aussi les entrepreneurs
qui eux prennent des risques qui eux se
font souvent pour la plupart en tout cas
les patrons pme et pmi qui se tuent à la
tâche pour trois à quatre mille euros
par mois donc c'est pas les rentiers qui
font fonctionner l'économie c'est et
c'est d'ailleurs en fait bien établi que
quand on donne un dirt plus à entier il
y en a beaucoup moins qu'ils reparlent
dans l'économie que quand on donne à
l'euro plus à quelqu'un qui en bas de
l'échelle des salaires parce que tout
simplement une dépense donc c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour
l'économie dans toute cette rente tout
s'est tu
et d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a un peu
oublié que les pères fondateurs du
libéralisme voulait se débarrasser de la
rentrée des ventes y est les patrons du
cac 40
comment se sentent ils comportaient
notamment sur leur salaire est ce qu'il
ya eu des efforts en ces temps de crise
sanitaire
c'est extrêmement variable et comme le
disait très bien votre journal y
certains patrons
du cac 40 n'ont pas le sens de la
décence et puis je suppose que
l'argument avancé va être de la
comparaison internationale
parce que vous comprenez si aux états
unis on gagne 400 fois ce que vienne son
salarié en france on a aussi gagné
quatre cents fois ce que gagne son
salarié moyen ski totalement
déraisonnable qui est absolument
injustifié et c'est évidemment un patron
d'une grande entreprise doit gagner plus
que son salarié moyen mais rien aucune
théorie économique ne justifie qu'il
gagne 400 500 fois ce que gagne son
salarié de base et c'est totalement
inefficace parce que c'est de l'argent
qui va partir dans des produits
financiers qui contribue à rendre les
économies plus instable donc on est une
fois plus dans luc brisson d'être une
fois de plus dans le déraisonnable
ça n'est guère surprenant et il est
temps que les personnes se rendent
compte à quel point ce système est
déconnecté y compris du bon sens et y
compris des théories économiques bien
qu'il se prête on économise d'avoir
était avec nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous en parlerons de la
biélorussie qui agit je cite légalement
déclarations d'alexandre loukachenko
devant le parlement trois jours après le
détournement d'un avion de ligne et
l'arrestation d'un opposant
et puis direction le mali ou le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies se réunit
pour examiner la situation
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend sa
fille
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam s'étant bien mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
adversaire même si je méprise totalement
son idéologie comme c'est le cas pour
sega liste
et puis
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
21h30 merci de rejoindre en direct sur
rt france le bras de fer se poursuit
entre la biélorussie et l'occident minsk
accusé aujourd'hui la france de
piraterie aérienne pour avoir refusé son
espace aérien à l'avion le forçant ainsi
à faire demi-tour canton dérouta de
l'avion de ligne de ryanair dimanche
dernier le président loukachenko
maintient qu'il était légale moscou sont
le disposé à le croire ce qui n'est pas
le cas des dirigeants européens et
américain à l'onu
europe et etats unis demandent une
enquête urgente de l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale
un décryptage signé été au combat le
décorum est impressionnant l'assemblée
d'avocats et d'officiels convoqué est
bondé ce mercredi face aux pressions
occidentales
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko est resté droit dans ses
bottes nas netapp rachat raté les zones
hier comme nous l'avions prédit nos
adversaires de l'étranger et à
l'intérieur du pays ont changé leurs
méthodes pour attaquer notre et a
franchi une multitude de lignes rouges
dépassant les limites de l'entendement
et de la morale humaine
il ne s'agit plus seulement d'une guerre
de l'information
mais d'une gehrig rythmes modernes et
nous devons tout faire pour éviter
qu'elle ne se transforme en un gros coup
des propos qui ne vont pas calmer les
tensions avec ses voisins européens
après avoir fermé leur espace aérien aux
avions biélorusse il pourrait décider
rapidement de nouvelles sanctions cause
de ces tensions l'arrestation de
l'opposant biélorusse romane
protasiewicz après le déroutage d'un
avion de ligne
dimanche dernier un acte condamnés par
les capitales occidentales mais pas par
moscou
ce qui intrigue le ministre français des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
l'absence de réaction de la russie vos
caution si d'aventuré le président russe
vladimir poutine voulait se démarquer du
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko il le ferait aux comptes
r il semble bien qu'on banalise cet
événement qui est un événement très
grave
des accusations que réfute le kremlin
à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons même pas
entendre une déclaration des pays
européens faisant part de leur volonté
de résoudre cette question pour autant
que nous sachions il n'a pas forcé
l'avion à atterrir et des idées par des
règles appropriées en cas de signes à
deux menaces
nous ne voyons aucune raison de ne pas
faire confiance à la biélorussie une
rencontre sera organisée ce vendredi à
sotchi en russie entre vladimir poutine
et alexandre loukachenko l'occasion
peut-être de répondre de nouveau aux
accusations unanime de l'occident pour
en parler nous sommes avec la danse
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir que l'autre
blanche maison merci d'être avec nous
pour bien contrainte soir qu'une demande
précisément l'europe l'europe devant
deux choses c'est très simple elle
demande d'abord la libération immédiate
de monsieur rose a fait vite ch est
également de madame syli a zappé ja
c'est à dire les deux personnes qui ont
été arrêtées dimanche après midi lorsque
l'avion la ryanair a été obligé de se
poser à minsk au lieu de ceux de se
diriger comme ça sa route que prévoyait
vers vilnius
et puis une deuxième chose l'union
européenne demande aussi que qu'il y ait
une enquête internationale objective et
que toute la transparence soit faite sur
les conditions dans lesquelles cet
événement a pu se produire
alors d'abord je crois qu'il faut
remarquer que tout le monde a été
surpris et sans doute monsieur le catch
est cool premier de la rapidité avec
laquelle les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont réagi
on dit toujours l'union européenne est
divisée c'est vrai souvent mais là 24
heures après l'événement ces décisions
sont tombées avec des sanctions et les
sanctions se sont comme vous l'avez dit
dans le sujet d'une part que les
vingt-sept demandent à leurs compagnies
aériennes de ne pas survoler l'espace ne
pas survoler la biélorussie et puisque
c'est dangereux
avec ou sans des dissidents à
l'intérieur des avions et d'autre part à
titre de réciprocité
elle interdit son espace aérien l'espace
aérien de ses états membres aux avions
biélorusse et par conséquent les nos
aéroports sont interdits aux avions
biélorusse et puis les 27 chefs d'état
et gouvernement
on demandait aux instances de l'union
européenne de réfléchir à des mesures d'
à des sanctions ciblées qui ne serait
pas supporté par la population mais qui
mettrait en cause les dirigeants de ce
pays
quand quelque chose à voir avec la
décision qui a été prise dimanche
dernier
et puis enfin là les instances
compétentes de l'union européenne vont
être appelés à allonger la liste des 88
personnes et entités qui sont
sanctionnés à savoir qu'elles ne peuvent
pas avoir de visa pour venir dans
l'union européenne qu'elle ne peut pas
détenir des comptes bancaires ou avoir
des avions des avoirs financiers à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
donc c'est un ensemble de sanctions
relativement modérée au bout du compte
qui ont été prises pour faire peser la
pression sur le président loukachenko
mais dans l'immédiat effectivement la
demande pressante c'est qu'ils libèrent
les deux personnes qui ont été arrêtées
dimanche soir alors justement après ce
vote détourné est ce qu'on peut imaginer
une enquête internationale digne de ce
nom
il faut une enquête internationale et
d'ailleurs la russie l'a souhaité
monsieur lavrov
l'adie très dès dimanche soir et le
gouvernement biélorusse a déclaré qu'il
était prêt à accueillir les enquêteurs
internationaux et qu'il était prêt à
jouer la transparence
alors je crois qu'il faut mettre le
gouvernement biélorusse au pied du mur
et que l'oaci qui se réunit demain son
conseil se réunit demain à montréal
la russie a fait partie bien entendu
tous les pays en font partie et bien
qu'on décide dans quelles conditions on
déclenche immédiatement l'enquète en
envoyant des enquêteurs compétent sur
place en biélorussie mais aussi sans
doute à athènes pour poser un certain
nombre de questions alors parmi les
questions à poser
il ya évidemment la liste des passagers
qui ont embarqué dans cet avion de
ryanair et qui a cette liste est bien
sans doute la compagnie ryanair mais
aussi l'aéroport date elle est aussi le
service des douanes et de la police des
frontières grecques
et puis de comparer cette liste avec la
liste des passagers quand atterri à
vilnius le point d'aboutissement de ce
vol et on constate comme tout le monde
l'a dit l'aéroport de vénus l'a fait le
savoir que effectivement il ya cinq
personnes en moins les deux qui ont été
arrêtées et trois autres personnes qui
pour des raisons qu'il appartiendra aux
enquêteurs de déterminer sont descendus
à minsk alors qu'il n'y avait pas d'
étape prévue à minsk
ça c'est un point qui devra être
éclaircies par l'enquêté puis par
ailleurs puisque les deux
le journaliste et sa compagne qui ont
été arrêtés dimanche soir n'était pas en
vacances en réalité en grèce il était un
forum économique à delphes une sorte de
davos grecs auxquels se trouvait aussi
madame d'éthique à minsk aia c'est à
dire
la seule à la dissidente qui s'étaient
présentés au moins d'août dernier contre
monsieur loukachenko et qui ensuite a
pris la tête des manifestations avant de
se réfugier à vilnius
elle était aussi à delphes à ceux à ce
colloque dans lequel elle devait faire
une communication à prendre la parole
compte tenu de ces éléments je suis
persuadé que la police grecque à des tas
d'informations sur ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce colloque est que les services
grecs sans doute aussi les services
biélorusse sava tas de choses sur ce qui
a pu se passer à athènes et il faut bien
que quelqu'un est informé le
gouvernement biélorusse de toute manière
des personnes qui étaient dans l'avion
et du fait que le journaliste dissident
était dans cet avion
donc cette enquête permettrait de
déterminer ces différents éléments et de
vérifier que les procédures utilisées
pour l'atterrissage forcé à minsk était
bien des procédures régulières prévu par
les traités internationaux
l'oaci est fait pour cela et il se peut
qu'il ait eu quelques entorses graves
retraités internationaux donc tout ça
devra être éclairci et je pense que
l'anc est le permettra on peut douter
en fait et c'est un peu le sens de votre
question peut-être que monsieur
loukachenko se prête de bonne grâce à
cette enquête
on verra bien il faut le mettre au pied
du mur que les enquêteurs se présente et
qu'il décrive la manière dont ils sont
accueillis et dont ils sont à même de
faire cette enquête
merci claude blanchemaison pour vos
précisions
et outre la biélorussie autre dossier
aujourd'hui sur la table du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies le mali le
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres est relayé par son porte-parole
appelle à la libération immédiate du
président de la transition et de son
premier ministre tous deux arrêtés lundi
soir par les militaires ont démissionné
selon les mots de baba cissé le
conseiller spécial du colonel keïta qui
assure que les négociations sont en
cours pour leur libération et la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
cette action a de sérieuses conséquences
sur le mali et la région nous demandons
à avoir accès aux détenus le plus tôt
possible
connaître les conditions de leur
détention et obtenir la garantie de
leurs droits fondamentaux comme stipulé
dans la charte internationale des droits
de l'homme monsieur vous terrestre
continue de réclamer la liberté
immédiate des leaders pour la transition
du mali nous travaillons de très près
avec les états de la commission
économique de l'afrique de l'ouest est
bien évidemment avec l'union africaine
mais aussi avec tous les autres acteurs
internationaux qui soutiennent la
transition politique en cours au mali
avec mériadeck
après journaliste spécialiste du mali
hauteur de touareg la révolte des hommes
bleus aux éditions economica bonsoir
mériadec raffray merci d'être avec nous
le président le premier ministre de
transition
mais bien qu'ils ont démissionné donc on
a appris aujourd'hui clairement est-ce
que ça signe l'arrêt de la transition
politique
bonjour c'est fini écoutez le nom c'est
au nez c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le
dire d'ailleurs
dans un communiqué le l'homme qui est à
la manoeuvre c'est à dire le colonel
goita qui est officiellement le vice
présidente 7 de cette formation de
transition et y est le l'homme fort qui
avait débarqué ibrahim boubacar keïta
hier en ou 2020 a dit que le processus
se poursuivrait que les élections
auraient lieu à l'automne c'est
évidemment un message pour rassurer la
communauté internationale et en
particulier la france les choses sont
quand même un peu compliqué à bamako ce
que l'on comprend aujourd'hui c'est que
ce les hommes forts de la gouvernance
qui gouvernent mali ce sont toujours les
militaires et ils ont voulu le montrer
par ce nouveau coup d'état dans le coup
d'état comme comme l'appelle emmanuel
macron qui l'a condamné hier avec jean
yves le drian
en réalité on a assisté encore à une un
nouvel accroc dans la gouvernance
malienne c'est quand même tout de même
relativement inquiétant ça a commencé à
peu près à mi mi mai par le gouvernement
a été déchiré démis le gouvernement de
transition et enfin en fait ça s'est
noué le 24 c'est à dire lundi si je dis
pas de bêtises en tout début de semaine
puisque en réalité le collège goïta a
refusé la nouvelle affiche qui était
proposée pour des raisons diverses et
variées le devront rentrer dans le
détail pour juste expliquer pourquoi les
choses se sont envenimées c'est que le
gouvernement avait mis de côté d'eux des
colonels de la junte militaire l'un qui
dirigeait le mystère de défense look le
mystère de la sécurité évidemment
c'était un signal négatif envoyé aux
colonels il sait il avait l'air de dire
que les politiques allaient reprendre en
quelque sorte une certaine forme
d'autonomie vis-à-vis des militaires il
ya aussi on dit aussi que les gens de
l'opposition de m5 ce qu'ils avaient
comment dirais-je manifester dans les
rues
juste avant le coup d'état de l'été
dernier n'était pas représenté dans le
gouvernement qu'après les problèmes de
corruption etc
donc tout ça c'est un peu à un peu
entremêlés il ya deux ex deux théories
qui circulent aujourd'hui l'une disant
que
dix ans l'une disant qu'en fait alors je
sais plus ce que je veux dire mais vous
allez me relancer alors on va te parler
cher mériadec raffray des réactions
parce qu'il y en a eu beaucoup et une à
l'instant à le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu condamne l'éviction des autorités
de transition on a vu que tout au long
voilà de ces dernières heures il y avait
des appels à la libération l'onu la
france vous l'avez dit ça veut dire quoi
que la marge de manoeuvre de la
communauté internationale elle est très
faible en réalité sasso le contente
d'aucune d'années est exactement alors
la marge de la marche mal et de la
communication n'ayant pas celui de l'onu
est très faible ce qui peuvent avoir une
incidence ou en tout cas une influence
sur ce qui se passe c'est évidemment la
france mais on voit que la france est à
nouveau décalée puisque la france a beau
jeu de condamner ce coup des terres dans
le coup d'état pour reprend l'expression
des mêmes macron alors qu'il y a environ
un mois emmanuel macron personnes
étaient à à djamena au tchad pour
comment dirais-je adoubé le fils du
président et disent débit le général
kaka de l'est général de 37 ans pour
prendre la succession de son père donc
d'un côté à n'djamena banal macrobe ni
un coup d'état un coup d'état pour
reprendre son expression à nouveau et
puis de l'autre côté à mois plus tard la
france 17 inacceptable envoyée il ya
quand même un sujet et ça ça pose un
vrai problème vis-à-vis de l'opinion
politique malienne la france se met à
nouveau comment dirais-je en difficulté
vis-à-vis de la légitimité du pouvoir
est telle qu'elle est on peut en
discuter mais bon c'est une c'est un
fait il ya eu plusieurs alertes ans
concernant la position politique
française au mali ces dernières mois
cette dernière année d'un en début
d'année il ya eu la sphère bounty la
première fois que l'armée française a
été accusée de dommages collatéraux par
une partie de la presse malienne
voilà donc il ya des rumeurs également
antilles françaises
ceux qui peuvent peser aussi sur les sur
ce qui se passe ce sont également les
américains ont ils viennent de dire ils
viennent de déclarer officiellement
qu'ils allaient suspendre leur aide
militaire à l'armée malienne alors
effectivement les américains sondés des
gros financeur en fait de l'opération
barkan et évidemment désarmé africaine
via des fonds et c'est donc ils ont un
pouvoir de manoeuvre ceci dit je ne vois
pas très bien les états unis aller
beaucoup plus loin
on va voir ce qui va se passer dans les
jours qui viennent si le pouvoir de
bamako laisse comment dirais-je donne à
nouveau des signes de normalisation de
la situation
ce qui pour l'instant paraît être
l'hypothèse la plus probable il faut
resté toutefois prudent
donc on l'attend pas grand chose du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui va se
réunir un bon jour dont je pense que
vous restez avec nous s'il vous plaît
mais n'y avait qu'à frais puisqu'on va
aborder un autre sujet en reste en
afrique puisque emmanuel macron est
attendu au rwanda ce jeudi c'est le
premier déplacement d'un président
français dans le pays depuis 2010 une
visite très attendue aux multiples
enjeux comme nous l'expliquent robin pu
l 27 ans après le génocide
emmanuel macron souhaite normaliser les
relations entre paris et kigali
des échanges entre les deux pays sont
empoisonnées depuis près de trois
décennies par le rôle de la france dont
le massacre des tutsis survenu en 1994
la publication du rapport du clair en
mars dernier dénonçant la responsabilité
accablante du gouvernement français de
l'époque a permis de relancer le
dialogue entre l'elysée et le pays
dirigé par paul kagamé l'enjeu
mémorielle sera donc au coeur de la
visite des manuels macron
alors que le rwanda attend toujours des
excuses de paris
le président s'adressera aux victimes de
génocide mais aussi aux rescapés
nous espérons trouver les mots justes
pour pouvoir parler à ces personnes
notre sentiment c'est que du côté de la
jeunesse africaine et de la jeunesse
française
il y as besoin de mettre des mots sur le
rôle exact de la france durant cette
période
nous allons répondre à cette demande de
compréhension mais ce déplacement revêt
aussi un enjeu économique
le président sera accompagné d'une
dizaine de chefs d'entreprises et par
les responsables de l'agencé française
du développement l'afd qui a relancé son
action au rwanda en 2019
au total près de 120 millions d'euros
ont été engagés entre autres dans la
santé l'énergie et l'enseignement ces
deux dernières années en réchauffement à
travers le prisme économique amorcée dès
2018 lors d'une rencontre entre les
actuels chefs d'état des deux pays
ils se sont mis d'accord pour travailler
sur des sujets qu'on crée d'intérêt
commun entre les deux pays
un certain nombre d'engagements ont été
pris à cette occasion qui ont
progressivement été mis en place depuis
d'arrivée d'un nouveau chargé d'affaires
à kigali le rwanda a eu des performances
remarquables ces dernières années et
peut être considérée comme une
plateforme potentiel de rayonnement
économique dans la région
lors de ce voyage les deux présidents
pourraient s'entendre sur le retour d'un
ambassadeur français à kigali où le
poste est vacant depuis 2015
l'occasion pour emmanuel macron de
concrétiser le retour de l'hexagone dans
une région considérée comme l'une des
plus dynamiques du continent africain et
on retrouve mériadec raffray pour parler
de cette visite emmanuel macron au
rwanda a présenté comme un acte fort le
signe d'une mémoire pacifié d'une
relation renouer ça c'est ce que nous
dit le porte parole du gouvernement
emmanuel macron qui affirme qu'il aura à
coeur d'écrire une nouvelle page entre
la france et le rwanda ce qui peut
clairement atteindre cet objectif
ça dans vous écoutez emmanuel macron
comme d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy
d'ailleurs y marche sur les traces de
nicolas sarkozy au rwanda force veut
absolument forcé comment dirais-je la
porte d'entrée du rwanda qui était resté
qui était resté
est fermé à la france depuis les
dramatiques événements des années
94 c'est à dire le génocide rwandais
pour une raison qui tient à la fois je
pense de l'idéologie et du business il
ya un mélange assez flou deux raisons
les les analystes sont assez dubitatif
on sait que nicolas sarkozy a à nouveau
repris du service pour comment dirais-je
pour le business franco-rwandais
puisqu'il travaille de manière
officielle aujourd'hui pour le groupe
accor notamment qui est intéressé pour
construire des hôtels voilà donc tous
athées est une est une comment dirais-je
éteindre un driver de la politique
française au rwanda qui se fait donc sa
force âge de portes qui se fait au prix
comment dirais-je d'une quasi réécriture
de l'histoire c'est le rapport du clerc
peut dire peut dire que la france était
coupable au rwanda en réalité ce rapport
a été signé par des historiens qui sont
clairement qu'ils ont clairement un
parti pris idéologique il suffit
simplement de ré écouter ce que dit
régulièrement dans les médias
quelqu'un comme hubert védrine par
exemple qui est qui n'est pas suspect de
déviance politique est clairement ces
gens là savent très bien que la france
est intervenue au rwanda pour tenter de
mettre de mettre fin de séparer les
belligérants et surtout de mettre à
l'abri les populations fils et civiles
de ce massacre épouvantable rwandais
voilà dans une situation compliquée et
je rappelle qu'à l'époque la france
était la seule à intervenir les états
unis qui soutient aujourd'hui critique
facilement la position française se sont
bien gardé d'intervenir à l'époque
c'était je crois si j'étais pas de
bêtises madeleine albright qui étaient à
la peine donc voilà donc à quel prix
doit encore faire du business avec le
rwanda j'en profite au passage pour
souligner le fait que kagame est en
général est aujourd'hui ne passe pas
pour un véritable grand démocrate au
sein de son pays
l'opposition enfin les paroles
d'opposition sont quand même
assez peu bienvenus un certain nombre de
morts sont chemine le choc chemin-là le
boulot tour du pouvoir et donc kagame a
sans doute une vie une image dans les
médias qui est très très tendance est
effectivement par l'ue pays aux mille
collines qui aujourd'hui à la pointe du
business en particulier dans le
numérique ça c'est pour les médias
occidentaux la réalité c'est que ceux
qui connaissent et qui suivent khayame
savent que c'est un général dictateur et
je mets un gars des guillemets sur ces
mots voilà encore une
comment dirais-je un paradoxe de la
politique africaine de la france qui va
au rwanda auprès de de ce2 du général
kagame mais qui se précipitent dans les
événements du mali pour condamner des
des officiers qui peut-être sont eux
légitime aux yeux de l'opinion publique
merci en tout cas beaucoup manier dakar
afin d'avoir été avec nous sur rtl
france au soir pour évoquer la situation
au mali et cette visite d' emmanuel
macron auront anbar ce sera donc demain
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
émission prochain point sur l'actualité
ce sera à 22h espérer
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on en dit beaucoup
d'angoissé beaucoup d'endroits de
l'autre les équipes de reprendre un
rythme avec en plus des restrictions qui
sont délicates pour travailler
correctement les projections de
croissance etc c'est exceptionnel on a
eu je doute qu'elles soient réalisées
aussi facilement que ça il va falloir
quand même avoir une vision de relance
il vient d'accompagner un peu plus
longue
on navigue presque un petit peu a vu
quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable ça fasse beaucoup
de dégâts parce qu'on va voir est le
deuxième coup fatal derrière et un autre
comme film en septembre tordre serait
dramatique pour la profession et
moralement de terribles où on nous vend
du rêve et malheureusement ça se
transforme vite en cauchemar
en féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes oser en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
faux
deux termes banlieue voir l'intensité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et en donne cette
impression de la banlieue ça serait une
vraie cas des jeunes violents contre une
police qui serait son travail c'est plus
compliqué que ça on est français on est
fiers de vivre dans ces quartiers même
s'il ya des difficultés est la moindre
des choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte canton quand on participe à la
vie de la société et malheureusement il
n'y a pas cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent et politique fort
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois leur concept et en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui peuplaient l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée enfin les français
ne savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france